I think this is hopefully just the
beginning I mean I think this is the
initial spark of what this protest is
about it's systemic so we need to start
like rooting out all the other causes of
the actual you know problem
welcome back to CBS this morning that is
some of the responses in Minneapolis to
the news that all four officers fired
after the killing of George Floyd have
been arrested other police critics are
targeting the president of the
Minneapolis Police Union which has been
a very powerful force against reform
efforts in a letter to members that
emerged earlier this week
lieutenant Robert Kroll seemed to refer
to the protest as a terrorist movement
and said that officers had been
illegally terminated in response a
former Minneapolis police chief called
Crowell quote a disgrace to the badge
Jamie yuccas spoke to her about the
department's history of racial issues
Jamie good morning to you what did you
find we found that the Minneapolis
Police Department's own statistics
revealed black people are more likely to
have excessive force used against them
than white people that's one thing
former city leaders say they want to see
change do you think there is an issue of
systemic racism within the police
department
Janee harteau is the former chief of
Minneapolis Police about 20% of the
city's population is black but according
to department data analyzed by the New
York Times Minneapolis police use force
against black people at seven times the
rate of white people just before George
Floyd's deaths prompted national outcry
prosecutors drew criticism for declining
to file charges against two Minneapolis
police officers in 2018 for the deadly
shooting of 31 year-old Thurman Blevins
police said they believe Blevins who
fled with a loaded handgun posed an
immediate threat to officer safety
three years earlier Jamar Clark was also
shot and killed by Minneapolis police
police said he was trying to grab a gun
and charges were never filed there is a
problem with policing in the city of
Minneapolis
Janee harteau stepped down as the city's
police chief in 2017 after another
deadly police shooting
she's now among the chorus of voices
including several Minnesota labor
organizations calling on police union
head Robert Kroll to resign earlier this
week he claimed in a letter that the
officers charged in George Floyd's
killing were fired without due process
do you think it's fair to point the
finger strictly at lieutenant Bob Kroll
no he is the loudest voice all of our
actions they have an impact in 2017
midoriya Arredondo took over for her toe
becoming minneapolis first black police
chief but a decade earlier he and four
other officers filed a discrimination
lawsuit against the department claiming
it's systemically and continuously
discriminated in favor of white persons
and subjected black officers to a
hostile work environment the complaint
also accused Kroll of making racist
statements and wearing a motorcycle
jacket with a white power batch the city
settled the lawsuit for seven hundred
and forty thousand dollars without
admitting liability the Minneapolis
Police Department will prohibit
fear-based trainings and just last year
when mayor Jacob Frye bans so-called
warrior training which teaches officers
to view all interactions as potentially
dangerous and equips them with a
readiness to kill cruel partnered with a
private company to continue offering
that training in my city and in cities
around the country we militarized
policing RT Rybak was the mayor of
Minneapolis from 2002 to 2013 we're at a
crisis point right now we can't do
everything overnight but we can stand up
and kneel down and recognize that this
is a moment in which we've got
to change we know that use of force is
disproportionately experienced by black
Americans across the country and
Minneapolis is no different
University of Minnesota sociology
professor Michele Phelps studies
policing
many people of color in the United
States grow up knowing that the police
can be a source of harm to them so I
think police reform is clearly on the
table right now and in a bigger way
perhaps than ever before but I think we
also need cultural change in society we
should mention that lieutenant Crowell
is married to an anchor at our
Minneapolis station WCCO TV and they say
she has not reported on the department
or Union issues for at least two and a
half years Anthony all right Jamie thank
you and we did reach out to Kroll for
comment but have not heard back